this episode is brought to you by Ridge
wallet
[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared you few artists have
had as big an impact on our image of the
apocalypse as Australian director and
actually fully trained medical doctor
George Miller Miller's vision of a
leather-clad post-apocalyptic wasteland
has captured our collective imaginations
since the release of Mad Max the road
warrior in 1981 and while we mostly tend
to think of Mad Max as that franchise
with more violent car crashes than lines
of dialogue these films hold our
attention because they and indeed most
of Miller's work explore big questions
around life death and power who owns the
body and what is it for who gets to
decide who lives and who dies and how
can we live full lives when death is all
around us
today we're going to explore George
Miller's answers to these questions and
more so go get some spray paint
flood your car with gasoline and witness
us as we dive straight into this
wisecrack edition on the politics of
life and death in Mad Max and babe and
spoilers ahead for grown men getting
straight-up horny over cars and again
also babe but before we continue I want
to give a shout out to this week's
sponsor Ridge wallet the ridge wallet is
a light sleek and industrial wallet
designed to last you a lifetime each
wallet is made with RFID blocking
technology which protects you from
digital pickpockets the durable metal
also means each wallet comes with a
lifetime warranty so this could be the
last wallet you ever buy it's perfect if
you don't want to carry around a bulky
old leather lump in your pocket but
still want to maximize the amount of
cards you carry it holds up to 12 cards
and still has room for cash I got the
titanium gunmetal wallet and nothing
beats how sleek it is the ridge team is
so confident that you'll like it that if
you don't and send it back within 45
days you will receive a full refund if
you're not in need of a wallet it's the
perfect gift for Father's Day which is
right around the corner grab your own
Ridge wallet today by going to Ridge
coms last wisecrack and use the promo
code wisecrack to get 10% off you'll get
free worldwide shipping and returns so
click the link in the description to get
one today and now back to the show first
a little scene setting George Miller's
Mad Max universe opens in a near-future
Australia were ultra violent motorcycle
gangs Duke it out with ultra violent
cops for control of the
protagonist Max Rockatansky family is
murdered in the first film and the
series follows him as he wanders the
wasteland in the wake of a nuclear
apocalypse struggling to survive turf
wars between rival groups while holding
on to some shred of his sanity to
understand a lot of what Miller does in
these movies we can turn to our old
friend and war Boy cosplayer philosopher
Michel Foucault Foucault spent much of
his career crafting and refining a
concept he called bio power in a
nutshell the idea that power in all its
forms has increasingly come to bear on
life and biological function the bio
power according to Foucault involves the
calculated management of life the
subjugation of bodies and the control of
populations and distributing the living
in the domain of value and utility in
short modern power isn't just about the
exercise of force but building and
managing a population this management
plays a big role in the politics of the
wasteland Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome for
instance revolves around the fight
between anti entity and Master Blaster
for control of Bartertown
a settlement that literally runs on
biological activity specifically the
methane produced from pigs and relies on
prison labor to process said feces and
in Mad Max fury road
immortan joe uses the tried-and-true
biopolitical technology of chastity
belts to control his wives reproductive
capacity and horded for himself but the
concept of bio power can only take us so
far in our analysis of Miller's work to
go deeper we have to move past the
politics of life and explore the
politics of death in his 2003 essay
necro politics Cameroonian philosopher
and political theorist a shield member
formulated the idea of necro power as an
update to fuko's concept of bio power
according to Ben batt much of the world
now runs on political machinery that is
designed not to protect and control life
but to produce deaths in vast quantities
as he explains it necro politics
involves the generalised
instrumentalization of human existence
it brings about the creation of death
worlds new and unique forms of social
existence in which people take on the
status of living
obviously in Bemba isn't writing some
Walking Dead fan fiction rather he means
that in a jurisdiction permeated by
necro politics such as a slave powered
plantation or an area subject to
colonial rule members of certain groups
are allowed to live so long as they are
useful but denied status as fully
sentient human beings with their own
rights and subjectivity these people are
physically or psychologically maimed to
mark them as the lesser man in this way
they are kept in what in Bemba refers to
as a state of injury this state of
injury is rampant in the world of Mad
Max these movies love to explore the
weird and terrifying ways that
near-future Australians degrade each
other into mere objects in the road
warrior a gang strapped prisoners to the
Front's of their cars to be used as
living hood ornaments
moreover gang boss Lord humungus
arguably even puts his own fighters into
a state of injury by classifying them
not as people but as animals and in fury
road people are reduced to all kinds of
weird objects meant to serve immortan
joe's needs Max is kidnapped and turned
into a blood bag immortan joe keeps a
collection of lactating women hooked up
to an industrial pumping machine to
produce mother's milk and then of course
there are immortan joe's wives or as
they're known around the Citadel freitas
these prize breeders in immortan joe's
eyes these women are property
instrumentalized in in bamba's terms
to the point where he keeps them behind
a literal bank vault door as if they
were a stash of gold bars or the last
remaining copy of final fantasy 7 he
values their lives only insofar as they
can make his babies against this necro
political backdrop where a human life is
presumed to be a resource rather than an
end in itself Ben Beck claims that
people tend to use one of two basic
strategies to find meaning and make life
bearable the first and most obvious is
the logic of survival he approached the
life that finds satisfaction and being
the last person standing
max embodies this logic throughout the
series and explicitly voices it in the
opening shot of fury road a man reduced
to a single instinct
so five more complex is the logic of
martyrdom the way of thinking that
drives suicide bombers kamikaze pilots
and so on to kill large numbers of
people by killing themselves according
to been bad when the logic of martyrdom
is in full swing the besieged body
becomes a piece of metal whose function
is to sacrifice to bring eternal life
into being this logic finds its fullest
expression in the cult of the v8 the
religion that encourages the war boys to
win eternal life by dying in service to
immortan joe Nux for instance deals with
his hellish life and impending death by
cancer who fantasizing about the
opportunity to die a glorious death if
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die historic on
the fury road more than anything else
the dying knucks desires eternity in the
form of Valhalla high then I die when he
fails to kill furiosa he frames that
failure as the loss of his one chance at
eternal life I should be walking with
the immortal no feasting with the hero I
was a fun time and speaking of McPhee
sting so far we've been discussing how
George Miller explores questions around
life death sovereignty and so on through
Mad Max but George Miller isn't just a
former medical doctor who directed the
Mad Max series throughout his career
Miller has been involved in a variety of
genres among them dark fantasy medical
drama and children's films including
Believe It or Not babe and Happy Feet
weirder still throughout all these
movies biopolitics
and necro politics still loom large not
convinced allow us to reintroduce to you
what is arguably the most sexual of
penguin based children's movies some
might say too sexual I will retire now
to my couch of Perpetual Indulgence
Happy Feet follows The Adventures of a
mumble a penguin born in the midst of a
fish shortage to a society organized
around the act of singing when his
father Memphis realizes that mumble
wants to dance rather than sing he is
deeply alarmed
kind of cute but it just ain't fans whoo
okay Emperor land fetishizes singing and
identifies it as the only legitimate way
to find a mate this behaviour lines up
neatly with fuko's description of the
so-called science of sex that developed
in conjunction with bio power for
instance he notes how the strange
pleasures of individuals were long
considered harmful to all important
population health in contrast proper
normal sex allegedly ensured a
physically vigorous population in other
words getting down in a non-traditional
way came to be seen as literally
dangerous to the health and safety of
your neighbor your country etc it's on
these grounds that the community elders
attack mumbles tap-dancing is this kind
of backsliding this has brought the
scarcity a bonus her the emperor
penguins bio political logic the only
safe and healthy way to channel sexual
energy is through singing anything else
is seen as a direct threat to the
well-being of the group bio power plays
a similar role in Miller's The Witches
of Eastwick the entire plot of this dark
comedy revolves around a sexual
relationship between the devil and three
women who unknowingly summoned him to
their conservative New England town the
town's folk condemn their behavior as
not just immoral but dangerous like
immortan joe Jack Nicholson's devil
ultimately seeks to use the women in his
life as vessels for his offspring a fact
recognized only by the hilariously
unhinged about churchgoer Felicia who
slowly loses her mind imagining the
sinful stooping
he will increase this number moreover
many of Miller's non Mad Max projects
also engage heavily with necro power by
exploring questions around who lives and
who dies
and why nominal kids movie babe explores
the state of injury through the lens of
life on a farm from the get-go the
actually horrifying film makes it clear
that the farm animals lives depend on
their ability to provide utility to the
hog 'its or as memba might say their
lives depend on how they can
instrumentalize themselves if they can't
do that while alive well there's always
dinner to think about like the
population of the Citadel the animals
are grouped into a rough caste system
based on the role they play on the farm
the exact mechanics of this divide are
spelled out by Ferdinand a duck who
tries to steal the morning crowing
responsibilities in order to become
indispensable to the Hoggins humans
don't eat cats why humans don't eat
boosters why everyone up in the morning
animals lower in the hierarchy are kept
in a state of injury where they are
reduced to the food items that they are
destined to become the tragedy of the
necro political arrangement is that it
gives the half lives
pork chop and blood bag to the world
only one way to experience something
approaching personhood to feel out death
and violence themselves and this point
is subtler in babe than in Mad Max the
pig only gets as far as biting a sheep
on the leg but we can dream can't we Ben
Beck claims that under necro politics a
person becomes a subject that is a fully
individually to human being in the
struggle and the work for which he or
she confronts death and upholding the
work of death in other words the extent
to which you are allowed to be a unique
person is determined by how much killing
you can do if you're a victim you don't
matter
throughout the Mad Max franchise the
right to define oneself is limited
mainly to men an occasional woman who
have the power and the will to subject
others to violence and death employing
flamboyant costumes and monologues
characters distinguish themselves from
the drab multitudes by killing
effectively and with a particular sense
of style as a member points out murder
and a necro political environment tends
to become over the top even perversely
playful in the wasteland it helps to be
a bit of a ham toecutter and his gang in
particular the ill-fated Knight Rider
dem
straight the link between killing and
personhood using violence and chaos as
opportunities for ego primping the
speeches and codpieces get bigger in the
road warrior with humongous employing
what appears to be a full-time hike man
[Music]
and the trend continues through fury
road with Knux feeling most like a
person when attempting a suicide run on
the war rig not to be outdone the bullet
farmer responds to the loss of his eye
with a speedy personal rebrand
strikingly max actually avoids defining
himself in terms of his violent deeds
what do I call you does it matter
Max and other words has been so warped
by his time in the wasteland and by the
logic of survival that he doesn't even
want an identity to take a name after
all is to make a kind of stand a
liability for a person who just wants to
drive away from trouble as far and as
fast as he can and yet for a guy who
makes movies about sexual assault
suicide bombings and horny penguins
George Miller injects his stories with a
surprising amount of hope caught up in
cruel biopolitical and necro political
systems his protagonists ultimately find
ways to transcend those systems and live
in ways that leave the world better than
they found it in other words they find
the redemption that Max and furios are
looking for and in the process becomes
subjects without resorting to pointless
killing just before the world goes
completely to a pre wasteland max
expresses his fear of losing himself
should he spend too much time on the
road I'm scared you know why
[Music]
I'm beginning to enjoy what is this body
week look any longer out on that road
and I'm one of them you know a terminal
crane which of course is exactly what
happens
max loses his family takes revenge on
toe cutters gang and begins his descent
to the condition we find him in at the
beginning of fury road a man reduced to
a single instinct survive beginning with
the road warrior Miller challenges us to
imagine a way back for max that is a way
for him to live again man haunted by the
demons of his past a man who wandered
out into the wasteland the way to live
again it turns out is to fight back
against the logics of necro politics
namely survival and martyrdom to take
actions that put one's own life at risk
and have some greater purpose beyond
taking as many possible people with you
when you die babe finds out how to live
in a necro political environment by
learning to herd sheep with kindness
rather than cruelty after his one
attempt at being an [ __ ] to the Sheep
fails to get him any results babe
commits to simply asking them nicely to
move all the nice little pig like you
need to his ass with this radical new
approach babe creates for himself a form
of subjectivity not bound to the cycle
of dominance which fly describes earlier
in the film he is neither a pork chop
nor a wolf as the terrified sheep called
the violent dogs he is the sheep Pig
this dynamic of taking a riskier less
efficient action for the benefit of
friends rather than the destruction of
enemies is also key to the redemption in
fury road in his final moments nuts
transcends the normal logic of martyrdom
by turning his body into a shield that
saves his friends rather than a weapon
to be used against his enemies he gives
his life not out of hatred for the other
but out of love for the first people in
his life who have recognised him as
anything more than a fanatical soldier
as he crashes the rig blocking the past
and allowing the others time to escape
his new friends become the first people
to truly honor his request to witness
him driving away and gracing him with
the same hand signed abou Bellini used
to honor their dead they recognized him
as the full person he could never become
as long as he worshipped in Morton Joe
similarly max becomes a subject by
transcending the logic of survival
rather than taking the motorcycle
offered to him and driving far far away
he concocts a wild plan to drive
straight back the way they came through
immortan joe's forces to take the
citadel for themselves
in other words max risks his own life
for the chance to create a better life
for the people he's come to care about
this allows him to become a subject
outside of the necro political framework
to reclaim his name my name is max now
none of these endings are quite that
simple at the end of the day babe is
still an unpaid farm labourer who could
be turned into spareribs the moment he
stops being useful and furiosa and
company find themselves in control of a
massive war machine it'll take a lot of
work to deprogram a citadel full of war
pups but at a minimum miller offers us
hope that in a world too often polluted
by coercion and violence we can find a
way to be something other than victims
or perpetrators as Max's one-time
commanding officer puts it they say
people Davin you want me max babe max
furiosa and knucks
all proved themselves to be bigger than
the labels put on them by the necro
political power structure babe is a
sheep Pig not a pork chop
furiosa is a freedom fighter not an
Imperator knucks is a loverboy not a war
boy and Max is more than a man reduced
to a single instinct he's a human and as
hard as that can be sometimes so are we
but what do you think wisecrack where
can you see biopower and necro power at
work in our world today what are some of
your favorite stories that grapple with
these and similar themes let us know in
the comments below and be sure to
subscribe and ring that Bell big thanks
to our dope patrons for supporting the
channel and our podcasts stay shiny stay
chrome and as always peace
[Music]